the story here from from Business
Insider the US has the world's highest
coronavirus death rate and more than
five percent a number that reflects the
country's lack of testing I'm going to
say technically yes but it hit a nursing
home so why you know why do we have a
disproportionate amount of people who
are you know who've died give their old
hit a nursing home for the old people
you know it's like my heart goes out to
people who lost their lives true but
they're the most susceptible so that's
just it's not rising but but of course
this is the number one post on Reddit
right now and I do think I do think we
should be concerned you know 5%
mortality and so one of the things
they're bringing up is that as a lack of
testing and this was actually Trump's
point it's weird because I'm seeing
people in the comments say like they're
blaming Trump for not doing a good
enough job and I'm like but he said this
yesterday he got dragged for it yeah he
said that the number will actually go
down once the CDC tests go out right and
we're and we're working on it we
actually test people yeah and they've
also cancelled South by Southwest which
for those that aren't familiar I guess
it started as a big Music Festival
Annesley don't know exactly no I know
I've been there and it's stupid now it's
the supreme of music
oh yeah supreme I think I'm just I don't
know everybody South by Southwest I know
wait that's the one in Austin I'm
thinking of Coachella
I think Austin's still cool no you're
wrong you're wrong live in Austin Austin
is cool
so imagine a got dude with black frame
glasses wearing a button-up shirt tucked
into his his cat into his blue jeans
with a brown leather belt and he's doing
this like really weird awkward dance
that's South by Southwest that's like
I'm not that tense go like just like you
know nice so I went there and I was all
excited like oh cool South by Southwest
I got it I got invited to speak mm-hmm
no one does anything they're not like
the panels are all empty no one does
anything what is it then it's a bunch of
stodgy nerdy corporate dudes getting
drunk oh okay
so if you're like the middleman
basically is Coachella I've never been
to Coachella I've been I've never been
it's Coachella either but I just hear
that it's turned from a cool music thing
into like this who's who of being able
to go places oh yeah and post their
pictures of proof on it
it's the people who wanna make the
highlight reel life yeah let's let's
read that let's let's look let's read
about the coronavirus and then we can
rag on sulfite yeah okay so the story
from aol.com they say the US has the
world's highest death rate for the new
coronavirus based on the ratio of
confirmed deaths to report cases five
point four percent of patients have died
that's far higher than the global rate
of 3.4% at the World Health Organization
reported on Tuesday and even hired
higher than mainland China's three point
seven okay hold on three point seven
that's even higher yeah remember
remember people were saying was two
percent yeah in China uh-huh now it's
three point seven sneer Lee doubled
that's the Chinese been reporting are
they lying to us and if they're lying is
it are they undercutting they're
undercutting of course oh all right
three point seven no no here's here's
the challenge if they want to keep
things under rap they're gonna say the
amount of reported cases is way down
exactly you know so they might have
hundreds of thousands and no it mm-hmm
everyone's like locked in their house
now there was a video that came out
where it was someone in their window
yelling at the officials who are walking
around but everyone's quarantined
basically like like everyone yeah I got
a message from someone and they said to
me there's an interesting point isn't it
strange how all of the leaked videos
have stopped what's really gonna yeah
from China so I think it's way worse and
they're only claiming things are better
because the markets going nuts did you
see what that guy from CNBC said earlier
no he said it'd be better if everyone
just got coronavirus so he can get over
it yep and then you get 3.7% people
dying can't apologize for it he's like I
mean but he was saying that the Marg
meant he did yeah he totally meant but
it was because the markets are going
nuts like and so down and up and down
and up yeah yeah yeah it fell again
today and he was like it'd be better for
the global economy if everyone just got
it
there was actually a lady in the UK one
of the doctors who works with the NHS
and she was saying that it would be
better if they got the coronavirus to
and a bunch of people died because then
they'd have beds open is that
utilitarians yeah I would say so yes
super practical bring back natural
selection I like I like the the contrast
utilitarian versus gentle
the we must protect all individuals
because their life matters versus the
well filled people died we'd have more
beds for young people that's what that's
what Bloomberg was saying that if you're
like 90 and you go to the hospital it's
like well okay to be fair a lot of those
people that are getting up there they
choose not to be resuscitated the
choices right they sign DNR's and they
choose not to have those elective
surgeries sure do you have a choice
you're right you're right that's the key
difference
all right let's read so that actually so
we don't we don't have the highest in
the world I was wrong about this I
thought we did that was incorrect on my
part I messed that out didn't say that
oh no okay yeah I thought it I thought
it did and I guess I got this wrong it
says only the Philippines has a higher
coronavirus death rate in the US and
that's because it only had three cases
okay okay so I think I'm technically
right and technically wrong for a lot of
reasons but I have to apologize for any
because I shouldn't have done that
oh it only had three cases and one
person died so it's a 33 right that's a
ridiculous one and the guy was from
Wuhan China okay okay okay they say it
is highly unlikely that the corona virus
is more deadly in the US rather the
number is likely to likely the result of
limited testing in the u.s. because
widespread testing wasn't possible in
the country in recent weeks the CDC held
stringent standards for who qualified
for a test until Wednesday the agency
only tested people who had recent
exposure to a confirmed patient had
traveled to a country with an outbreak
or required hospitalization so the US
has not tested or diagnosed too many
patients with mild cases there's a quote
here there's another whole cohort that
is either asymptomatic or minimally
symptomatic Anthony Fauci director of
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Disease said in a February 6
briefing we are going to see a DeMint
Dimmie diminution diminution in the
overall death rate I'm too tired for
this yeah as it's gonna go down
diminution as of Thursday the u.s. is
national coronavirus count was 221 that
total includes results from state-level
coronavirus testing implemented more
widely implemented more widely the CDC
had only confirmed 99 cases across the
country as of Thursday at noon if you
calculate the death rate based on only
those the federally verified cases it
jumps to roughly 10 percent yeah but
they're also saying that
most people who have gotten it have mild
- like almost nothing like a chain dude
okay let me get like really bad flu
symptoms it's just kind of like oh I got
a cough and then it goes away and right
that's the extent of it in the so you
know I try to keep politics to a minimum
but this is you know you can't it's you
can't separate it especially the CDC
response Trump gave an interview where
he said a lot of people will get it and
they'll just get better not realizing
the virus right and he said some people
even go to work without even realizing
it and you know they get better right
what are the media say Trump encourages
people to go to work with coronavirus of
course I'm sure what is this man
Trump haters they just want to make
stuff up just make it up that's that's
the world we live in okay but hold on
hold always someone out there that hates
on pretty much everything I now have
probably the best update ever oh this is
funny
demand for toilet paper at Mount Druitt
Kohl's is so high today there's a
security guard stationed permanently in
the toilet paper aisle to monitor the
situation quote we're going through a
pallet every ten minutes or so he said
wow that's a lot of TP that's Australia
man at first I thought it was America
Hallett every 10 minutes pallet could
you imagine
yes knots I can how like these people
got big butts you know I mean I don't
situation in correlation with toilet
paper ever that's when I but that's
where we are now
all right don't like it when I first
heard this I thought it was America that
was doing this yeah I'm lying well can't
be surprised Americans you know
Americans eat a lot kind of gross kind
of kind of big people and then I was
like wait a sauce trail yeah yeah stray
Lea's Terrence they're told they were
but it's happening everywhere so this
story that I talked I talked about it
earlier
Home Depot Kroger's and Kohl's are
limiting purchases to slow down panic
buying over coronavirus toilet paper and
face masks are flying off the shelves in
a mad frenzy I did not expect the toilet
paper thing I didn't think about that
either yeah look at this picture the
toilet paper rack is just empty there I
don't know where that is I think it's
the same photo from where this guard is
oh no maybe not is it is it no it's not
it's not the same store if they're not
but I'll tell you what man you may have
heard about happen in Tennessee
the tornados yeah yeah so I was saying
this earlier uh I hope everyone's safe
yeah you know my heart goes out to those
that got hurt but you as I pointed out
and the last time we talked about this
I've been saying go to the store pick up
some gear
yeah because disasters happen and I got
all these people on Twitter
smack-talking doodooing to tell people
to go buy stuff
could you imagine the people who are in
Nashville who are like I better go buy
stuff over the coronavirus yeah and now
they have supplies roads might be closed
they're out you know yeah crazy I drove
through that that exact spot a week
before man I went right out right it's
like glad I did it the week I did it
it's crazy when nuts well it was it's
like we talked about with Sandy you go
there one day everything's fine yeah and
then at night you're like what's wiped
out exactly it reminds me it reminds me
of like how much your world can change
in a split second like there was one
video I saw where a guy was it was a it
was a football match I think I think was
maybe soccer I can't remember okay but
some player got angry because of referee
gave him a bad call so he like started
yelling and then he banged his head on
the goalpost and then just went rigid
and fell over paralyzed himself from the
neck down he head-butted the goalpost
and got paralyzed he banged his head on
it because he was angry you know and
then he immediately just went rigid and
falls over and like man I'm imagine what
that night for life from their life for
life yeah haha he banged his head it
cracked it hit split his neck or
something hit a nerve and he fell over
and couldn't move - the adrenaline must
have been rushing he banged his he was
he was like angry the ref called it and
it's like was it worth ending your your
career no man but you seriously I think
banging your head but I'm not I'm not it
is a bit of a derailment start talking
about that but I just bring it up
because like one day you go to the store
they got all the TP in the world and
you're like auntie pew tomorrow right
and then a storm happens or a corona
virus happens now you can't wipe your
butt and that would be a shame I'll tell
you this though I wouldn't watch that I
would I would you I would much rather be
in my bathroom I mean looking down at
the roll and seeing it like nothing
there but one little piece and going no
than being paralyzed
true I'll take I'll take the toilet
paper rush on the stores yeah well let's
take a look over at South by Southwest
see what's going on that says so they
say the annual tech music and Film
Festival will not proceed after all and
I say good riddance good sir um I I
think it is it is is fake event I really
do think it's fake
yeah I went there years ago I got
invited I almost missed it because I
like overslept my flight mm-hmm and then
the people they were like no no you got
to come you got to come just try it just
go there and tell him you missed your
flight and they'll rebook you on a later
flight they did so I made it and I was
all excited cuz I was on his panel about
New Journalism okay that's actually
where I met brian Stelter from CNN okay
and there was ten people in the audience
and I felt bad I was like I felt bad I
was like man like I guess our panel is
just bad and we're like nobody's doing
nothing and nobody want to show up it
turns out no that's normal in fact we
had one of the one of the were the most
uh the biggest biggest turnout for a lot
of these panels ten people like I'm not
kidding I was like ten people that
surprised me because just fake that's
not notoriety to like be seen at you
know in the audience at your panel and
that's what put it'll go to these places
for no I don't think so I I realized
that when I saw the most people it was
just afterwards at the barbecue shop or
they were buying drinks and bragging
about Texas barbecue yeah exactly how's
it and so what what I found was I I went
there because there were some tech
people who you know we're like oh you're
gonna be there we're gonna meet with you
and talk about tech and live streaming
and mobile stuff I'm like awesome and
what did they do standing in the street
drunk dancing and I was like so we gonna
talk about when are we gonna talk about
and they were like dude and I'm like no
that's not what I'm here for
I'm gonna go do something else ya know
left and I was I end up doing some
activist tea thing like teaching people
how to do livestream or something let's
go I thought it was terrible
i-i've never want to go back I got I
think I got invited or or asked to be
I've got asked to be a part of it a
couple times since then and I'm just
thinking you will never get me to go to
another thing I got things to do man it
was it felt like it felt literally like
being put in purgatory like someone took
me and said we're going to waste your
time now for the next several days sit
down and I was like dude did that not
drive you crazy I could see of course
I was banging on walls no it was just it
was just boring okay we should actually
I sense a pretty cool place though
outside of this I got a buddy lives
outside there I mean maybe for music
it's cool cuz I I you know the people I
knew in Chicago playing music we're
always excited about wanting to go and
like play a set at one of the venues
during South by ok and it's just so
maybe maybe the music portion of it is
still good I think I think the music was
always better and they added everything
else because they're like oh look at
this big thing we got well let's take
let's actually read about the the
coronavirus shutting them down yeah well
they tweeted it I'll just read with
their statement is they said here's an
update on please read our full statement
here I'm not gonna read The Verge we'll
just read what they actually said
assuming it loads properly the City of
Austin oh whoa Austin canceled it is it
run by Austin has canceled the March
dates for South by Southwest and South
by Southwest edu South by Southwest will
faithfully follow the city's directions
yeah Wow the city shut it down nice we
are devastated to share this news with
you
the show must go on is in our DNA and
this is the first time in 34 years the
March event will not take place we are
now working through the ramifications of
this unprecedented situation
yeah the loss of probably like tens of
millions of dollars and the City of
Austin as I'm to do that to you as
recently as Wednesday Austin Public
Health stated quote there's no evidence
that closing South by Southwest or any
other gatherings will make the community
safer however the situation evolved
rapidly and we honor and respect the
city of Austin's decision we are
committed to do our part to help protect
staff attendees and fellow Austinites we
are exploring options to reschedule the
event and are working to provide a
virtual south-by-southwest
online experience as soon as possible
for twenty twenty participants starting
with South by Southwest edu with edu for
our registrants clients and participants
will be in touch as soon as possible and
will publish an FAQ we understand the
gravity of the situation for all of the
creatives who utilize South by Southwest
to accelerate their careers is that what
you Cohen for their global businesses
and for Austin and the hundreds of small
businesses venues theaters vendors
production companies service industry
staff and other partners that rely so
heavily on the increased business that's
South by Southwest attracts we'll
continue to work hard
bring you the unique events you love
though it's true that our March 20 2008
will no longer take place in the way
that we intended we continue to strive
toward our purpose out being creative
people achieve their goals that is rough
that's crazy how many people that are
out of work now probably money that are
just taking it they're probably screwed
because they rely on these jobs every
year oh yeah they're not working those
festivals there's probably a man pa is
sure real and so many people are screwed
because of us and that sucks
and might not feel bad for you right now
whoever you know little Timmy
the bass player in the rock star the
upcoming rock star band just Scott word
a telegram I'm sorry but your your
performance has been canceled and he
limps over in his little crutch and he
says please South by Southwest just one
event no coronavirus so now you have
another of the March dates does that
mean
yeah that's now it's March well does
that so there's an April April dates I
mean no I can't imagine they could pick
this up because and they're trying to do
some online things so they're not giving
people their money back that's that's
the game's like sorry you had to cancel
we're keeping all the money we'll do an
online thing what's an online thing what
what's the use ich ins are gonna like go
in their basement do an acoustic set at
the microphone sky yeah then sight for
the fans they're gonna get the speakers
to go on a multi skype thing like a four
way Skype to talk about their ideas at
least they're safe from the coronavirus
ten online experience what if I mean I
mean look they're canceling tons of
conferences Google I would cancel
Facebook what is it all these tech
companies in Seattle like Facebook and
Amazon we're like everyone work from
home from now on yeah Twitter what if
what if you ever see the movie
surrogates no there's the one with Bruce
well have you seen it it's where
everyone has like a robot that walks
around for them and they stay in home
they stay at home all day and they go
inside this like I don't know it's a
little bed of some sort and they put on
like glasses or something and then it
transfers like they go into their avatar
or their surrogates are there certain
not their avatar but the different
movies a robot yeah well yeah you
mentioned avatar is basic it's like
similar but so no one ever leaves their
houses
and they walk around looking perfect
because they're like robot versions of
themselves and then you see like Bruce
Willis looks all like he looks fantastic
you're gonna sue like it's got his hair
parted or like slick to the side and
then when they go to his house and you
see him he's got like a scraggly old
beard and he's like out of shape yeah
and you know just looking miserable and
awful because everyone's just replaced
themselves with surrogates I like the
movie this pretty cool movie interesting
yeah Ving Rhames in it I don't I don't
give too much away if you didn't see it
but it's it from a while ago okay but
it's cool cool idea and there's one part
where like like the plot of the movie is
that it's it I think it starts with this
some dude like a dude avatar and a chick
have it I keep thinking avatar surrogate
are like making out an alley and then
someone fires a weapon that kills kills
them somehow even though they're in
their avatars yeah and then when they go
to the house of tho of the hot woman
it's this morbidly obese massive dude
yeah of course gamer yeah I'm just I'm
just thinking about all this like we're
locking ourselves down we're working
from home we're barricading our doors is
that really gonna stop every like look
man your immune system gets stronger
these things are a part of life and we
can't catch all of them yeah I certainly
wouldn't want to advocate for ex parte I
know I think I understand what we're
doing I think it's a good idea I'm just
wondering if it can be stopped there
will come a time maybe this is it maybe
this is it maybe we can't stop it we've
already seen like CDC experts saying
cats out of the bag so yeah if that's
the case what happens is is locking
ourselves inside a waste of time is
canceling South by a waste of time I
don't know throw at the time no I don't
think what the CNBC guy said made sense
everyone should just get it no no people
should wash their hands anyway yeah yeah
I mean you could take precautions but
yeah places where people are coming from
all over the country maybe different
countries to go to South by Southwest
that might yeah that's probably it's a
good idea to shut it down yeah they're
not just people in Texas like oh go into
our festival it's like everyone goes
from all over the place so if you can
prevent it you should since we can't
treat it right not only that they're
probably traveling through the airports
you know so it's like all the people are
going through the airport boom in
Austin it's like man okay so yeah I get
it does make sense yeah yeah think about
this though how many people never wash
their hands all of a sudden are washing
their hands like the first time in a
long time it's wonderful it's great it's
like people don't wash their hands at
all in it I know that it's wrong with
people how many times have you gone to
like a public restroom you see the guy
just like walk out or the lady just walk
out yeah and you're like stop that's you
yeah I'm not gonna touch whatever hatch
whenever I dry my hands with the towel I
I was like I hate it when there's no
towel with the bull air dryer things
like a shank even though I grab it I
grab it and then I keep it open the door
with it I hate the pull open cuz you
know those people have to grab that
handle and they didn't wash the man
listen man listen and they're grabbing
it no what no I like to keep my immune
system strong okay so I lick doorknobs
you kidding what people are gonna take
the club out of context anyway that's a
joke welcome to comedy no I had a friend
who told me that like he was eating food
and he dropped it and like you know
people say five-second rule he picked it
up he's like man keep my keep my immune
system on its toes I was like can't
argue with that let me know when you
there was oh dude there's a crazy story
I read about this don't don't like take
your immune system stuff seriously there
was a dude who ate a worm on a challenge
I think it was a worm and he got a
parasite that killed him whoa yeah like
they found an earthworm look dude eat it
he was like yeah and he ate it and then
he was in the hospital like paralyzed
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you